bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est Science Publique votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat de
reportage de chroniques et d'analyse sur
public c'est la 90 minutes pour donner
du sens à l'actualité grâce à nos
experts et l'actu aujourd'hui c'est le
discours d'Emmanuel Macron ce matin sur
l'autonomie de la Corse le chef de
l'État on trouve la porte et donne la
marche à suivre il faut pour cela
l'entrée de la Corse dans notre
Constitution
c'est votre souhait
je le partage et je le fais bien
inscrire les spécificités corses dans la
Constitution il faudra un minimum 6 mois
de travail avec le gouvernement pour
écrire le texte il faudra surtout
l'accord des 3/5 des parlementaires et
donc de la majorité de droite au Sénat
l'autonomie de la Corse était le
possible est-elle souhaitable ce sera
notre premier débat dans une minute et
puis dans trois quart d'heure c'est le
nouveau poids géopolitique d'Elon musk
que l'on va sous peser dans un livre qui
vient de paraître le patron de Tesla
Twitter et SpaceX est accusé d'avoir
bloqué une offensive
ukrainienne contre la flotte russes
vraie quelle est cette constellation de
satellites qui fait de musk un acteur
important du conflit le milliardaire
génial et colérique roule-t-il pour
Donald Trump pour la Russie beaucoup de
questions passionnantes à aborder tout à
l'heure mais d'abord ce qu'il faut
retenir des annonces du président de la
République devant l'Assemblée de Corse
avec Flora sauvage l'espoir en ligne de
mire après plus d'un an de discussion
entre l'État et les dirigeants de l'île
de Beauté Emmanuel Macron a proposé
devant l’assemblée de Corse qu'une
nouvelle étape soit franchie le chef de
l'État donne 6 mois au gouvernement et
aux élus corses pour aboutir à un texte
constitutionnel et organique afin
d'inscrire les spécificités corses dans
la Constitution faisant en sienne l'une
des demandes historiques des
nationalesistes je ne veux ici préempter
aucun des débats démocratiques que
mèneront les forces vives en Corse
et la représentation nationale
je suis favorable à ce que les
spécificités de la communauté insulaire
Corse soit reconnue dans la Constitution
au sein d'un article propre celle d'une
communauté insulaire historique
linguistique et culturel de quoi
satisfaire les indépendantistes à la
tête de la collectivité territoriale
depuis 2018 on est sur une inscription
qui donnerait des droits à la Corse
nouveau des droits nouveaux à cette
communauté à cette autonomie il est
évident que notre jeu c'est ce sera donc
se rapprocher le plus possible de la
libération du 5 juillet parce qu'il y a
quand même coeur d'essentiel à préserver
le 5 juillet dernier les nationalistes
ont adopté un projet d'autonomie
plaidant pour un pouvoir législatif
confié à l'Assemblée de Corse les élu
corses réclament un statut de résident
la co-officialité de la langue corse et
l'inscription de la notion de peuple
Corse dans la Constitution
autant de lignes rouges pour Bruno
Retailleau le président du groupe LR au
Sénat farouchement opposé à l'autonomie
de la Corse or le chef de l'État aura
besoin d'une majorité des 3/5 au Congrès
pour graver dans le marbre de la
Constitution tout évolution
institutionnelle de l'île de beauté
l'autonomie de la corse est-elle
souhaitable est-elle possible c'est en
tout cas un chemin un chemin semé
d'embûches et c'est ce que l'on va voir
tout de suite avec mes invités Michel
verger Franceschi bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes professeur émérite
des Universités Béatris Gibbon bonsoir
et bienvenue vous êtes géographe et
directrice de la revue Hérodote Benjamin
Morel constitutionnalise bonsoir
Benjamin maître de conférence en droit
public à Paris de Panthéon à ça c'est
vous publiez ce livre la France en
miettes aux éditions du Cerf on est au
cœur des débats dont on va parler dans
cette actualité dans cette émission avec
nous en duplex également Jean-Christophe
et Angelini le maire autonomiste de
Porto-Vecchio président du groupe partie
de la nation corse je le dis en français
à l'Assemblée de Corse bonsoir et
bienvenue à vous et Laetitia cruca
éditoris politique évidemment à mes
côtés bonsoir Laetitia Michel Berger
Franceschi qu'est-ce que vous pensez une
question assez générale pour pour
démarrer de cette autonomie allez je
vais dire esquisser par le chef de
l'État
c'est revenir un petit peu à ce qui
était la Corse pendant des siècles parce
que vous savez la Corse n'a jamais va
vraiment dépendu de Gênes ou dépendus de
l'Angleterre du temps du royaume et donc
on a toujours été j'ai refait un article
récemment dans storia Corse en disant
que le moyen-âge était de retour parce
que dans nos petits villages très
éloignés de tout pouvoir central
l'écorce se gérait un petit peu sans
subir des lois très proches d'eux le
pouvoir central même Versailles
Versailles par rapport à Corte au 18e
siècle il faut voir la distance donc
prétendre que la Corse a toujours été
soumise et qu'elle a toujours été
conquise c'est une jolie formule on la
voit sur toutes les serviettes on les va
la voir sur tous les T-Shirts mais ça
n'est pas vrai les corps ceux qui n'ont
jamais été très nombreux il faut pas
l'oublier c'était 120000 habitants par
Napoléon est né c'est le trip 330 000
c'est le tiers de la ville de Marseille
à peu près c'est le 19 arrondissements
donc les tarifs de Paris et les corps
sont toujours eu une certaine autonomie
par rapport à un pouvoir central quel
qu'il soit la République a quand même
changé la République a fait beaucoup de
bien ça c'est une chose essentielle
depuis que les corps sont voulu devenir
français et on voulu le vote du décret
du 30 novembre 1789 pour s'unir à la
monarchie française le terme de
monarchie était mal choisi en étant en
novembre donc après le 14 juillet donc
on a voté un décret qui a été le décret
d'union de la Corse à l'Imperium un mot
latin le territoire français et donc
depuis il y a un vrai pouvoir et devrait
progrès dans tous les domaines on y
reviendra évidemment je vais vous donner
la parole à tous les deux évidemment
rapidement mais il se trouve que
Jean-Christophe Angelini a d'autres
rendez-vous et donc on l'a seulement
pendant une dizaine de minutes dans ce
débat je voudrais commencer avant de
vous donner la parole Monsieur le Maire
entendre un extrait de la locution
d'Emmanuel Macron quelle autonomie c'est
un peu la question qu'on va tous se
poser ce soir écoutez ce que ce qu'on
dit le prix dans la République
la nouvelle étape institutionnelle que
nous voulons lancer doit permettre à la
Corse de conserver son âme et son
identité tout en restant dans les bornes
de la République et de continuer ainsi à
bénéficier de la solidarité nationale
notre priorité c'est d'aider la
collectivité à répondre aux attentes des
Corses l'aider à bâtir l'espoir et la
sérénité
Jean-Christophe Angeli est-ce que c'est
une étape importante qui a été franchise
ce matin pour vous
dans le discours dans l'approche on a
bien vu une volonté claire de franchir
un cap un seul nouveau et je crois qu'il
y a dans la locution du président les
ferments d'une promesse importante des
mots forts ont été prononcés autonomie
évolution statutaire langue culture
identité
capacité à produire nos propres normes
donc incontestablement même si tous les
termes que nous connaissons depuis fort
longtemps et qui sont majoritaires dans
l'espace public et le champ
institutionnel Corse n'ont pas été
consacrés énormément que l'allocution
d'aujourd'hui marque oui une inflexion
nette je restais avec nous je vais
donner la parole à Benjamin Morel est-ce
que c'est une c'est encore flou ça doit
se définir mais quand même c'est là que
ça pose la question de l'unité
républicaine ce qui est en train de se
passer pour vous tout dépend du contenu
alors ça pose évidemment la question de
l'intérêt public parce qu'il nous a pas
échappé que concomitamment vous aviez le
président de la Région Bretagne qui
remettait qui redonné un rapport à
Elisabeth band pour lui demander
également l'autonomie sur des termes
corses donc là en effet il y a un effet
qui peut être un effet d'emballement et
ça c'est très très dangereux ensuite sur
le contenu on a un Emmanuel Macron qui
était très très offensif il a prononcé
le mot assassinat mais uniquement il y a
Yves en Colonna le mot Erignac n'est que
lié au mot et bien commando Erignac donc
vous voyez que le discours de 2018 de
Bastia et celui-là il y a un delta
extrêmement important il reprend les
termes des nations et d'une certaine
façon il s'adresse d'abord et avant tout
à eux en reprenant sa tombe de
signifiant rhétorique sur le fond
l'autonomie c'est un mot-valise ça veut
rien dire en réalité qu'est-ce que c'est
l'autonomie est-ce que savoir un pouvoir
normatif n'importe quelle commune
dispose d'un pouvoir normatif en réalité
à travers un pouvoir réglementaire
résiduel est-ce que ça veut dire un
pouvoir législatif c'est pas du tout la
même chose donc on va voir ce qui va en
être à ce stade là en effet les mots
sont importants le contenu lui est flou
Jean-Christophe Angelini jusqu'où
voulait pousser le curseur parce qu'on a
bien compris que là maintenant il y a un
processus de discussion ussion qui va
continuer d'abord entre corps et puis et
puis peut-être parallèlement et ensuite
avec le gouvernement c'est quoi pour
vous l'autonomie souhaitée
pour nous c'est ce qui fait le quotidien
depuis des décennies de dizaines
peut-être de centaines de millions
d'Européens de par le monde je ne
partage pas complètement l'analyse de
Monsieur Morel sauf sur un point qui a
été évoqué en creux c'est qu'on n'est
pas effectivement quand on évoque ces
questions dans une tradition établie en
France qui est Michel Berger que je
salue connaissais question par cœur le
fruit d'une langue longue pardon et
longue centralisation et donc on est
effectivement dans une République qui a
quelques difficultés avec le fait
régional de faire territorial et avec
ses identités particulières donc on voit
bien qu'il y a je vais essayer d'être
très concret c'est toujours compliqué je
reprends la main et je m'en excuse mais
par exemple sur la langue corse
qu'est-ce qui pourrait changer d'après
vous très concrètement l'autonomie pour
reprendre un bout de votre question
précédente c'est pour nous la capacité à
légiférer et à réglementé dans tous les
domaines à l'exception bien sûr de ceux
qui relèvent du régal c'est en cela
qu'il y a à mon avis aucune sorte de
péril pour la République dès lors que
les grandes matières qui sont du domaine
du régalien en vocation à rester dans ce
même secteur pour le reste vous parliez
de langue corse je vous rappelle quand
même que la Corse aujourd'hui n'est même
pas dans la capacité de fixer ses
propres dates de rentrée quel est
soumise en termes de rythme de contenu
pédagogique à un certain nombre de
règles qui pour spécifique qu'elle
puisse être n'en demeure par mois
calquer sur les grands modèles nationaux
donc je crois qu'il y a vocation
notamment matière éducative à imprimer
nos propres contenu à développer notre
propre pédagogie et bien sûr comme le
président lui-même l'a dit inscrire la
langue et la culture dans l'espace
massifié de l'enseignement public ok
rester encore avec nous quelques minutes
je sais que vous êtes pressé mais
vraiment je voudrais donner la parole à
battre régime là un temps de votre
réponse est-ce que vous êtes un peu
inquiète vous Béatrice j'entends
Jean-Christophe Angelini oui je suis un
peu inquiète par exemple pour dire on
fera nos programmes d'histoire parce
pense que c'est ça qui a derrière comme
on l'entend et on enseignera un certain
type d'histoire oui ça me préoccupe
parce que cette le récit national la
Constitution
l'histoire multicellulaire comme la
nôtre si chacun
évidemment si chacun se met à faire son
discours historique on a vu que dans des
écoles Diwan par exemple en Bretagne ils
avaient effectivement un enseignement
d'histoire qui était pour le moins
tendancieux donc il faut faire attention
à un certain nombre de choses là-dessus
donc oui sa main qui est de même par
exemple sur le rapport à la langue on
comprend très très bien l'importance de
la langue dans pour une partie de la
population corse parce que tous les
corps ne parlent pas le corps mais quand
on voit par exemple ce que ça donnait en
catalogue ou petit à petit on a supprimé
l'espagnol où il n'est resté que le
catalan
au bout d'une certaine façon ça a permis
de marginaliser une partie de la
population
c'est des tentations possibles je dis
pas que ce soit ça en ce moment mais ça
peut venir à l'idée et à partir de ce
moment-là la République une et
indivisible elle est un petit peu en
miette une dernière question et
peut-être réponse à ce cette réaction de
béatrigible Jean-Christophe Angelini
qu'est-ce que vous répondez face à ces
craintes qui s'expriment ici et ailleurs
d'ailleurs dans le champ politique aussi
on est on écoutera la réaction par
exemple du président du groupe LR au
Sénat dans quelques minutes qu'est-ce
que vous répondez à ces craintes qui
s'expriment
[Musique]
vos invités je ne partage pas encore une
fois ce terme de point de vue mais je
les trouve sans taquinerie en deçà du
président de la République humaine quand
il était dit aujourd'hui qu'à l'heure
d'une économie et d'un monde globalisé
on pouvait vivre d'identité multiple
qu'enseigner le corse n'était pas
attentatoire à l'enseignement du
français que parler de notre histoire et
la convoquer non pas dans un récit
mythié ou mythologique mais dans un
récit objectif n'était pas porté
atteinte à toutes les autres histoires
le ministre Darmanin lors de la
cérémonie commémorative de l'assassinat
du préféré a parlé de réconciliation des
mémoires donc je crois qu'il faut pas
poser les choses en thème d'exclusive on
a la thème je le redisense ça n'est pas
décrédibiliser ou marginaliser le
français qui a des centaines de millions
de locuteurs de par le monde quand la
langue corse est à un taux de
transmission familiale de l'ordre de 2
ou 3 % et sur le point de s'étale et moi
je considère que le corps n'est pas que
la langue des Corse c'est un bout du
patrimoine de l'humanité qui nous est
commun et qu'on a intérêt à préserver
dans l'intérêt du peuple Corse mais de
l'humanité toute entière donc ne
raisonnons pas en termes d'exclusive
c'est une démarche ouverte de tolérance
d'accueil d'humanisme et poser
l'autonomie de la Corse avec cette
capacité à légiférer à réglementer dans
un ensemble global ça n'est pas porter
atteinte à qui que ce soit c'est
simplement trouver un chemin de paix en
dehors de toute violence politique en
dehors de toute surenchères et dans la
claire conscience qu'on peut réinventer
un pacte entre la République l'Europe et
la Corse pour peu que l'ensemble des
parties s'accorde sur un minimum si
chacun se réfugie des réactions on va
pas y arriver ce sera le défi évidemment
des prochains mois merci beaucoup
Jean-Christophe Angelini je vous laisse
repartir je crois vers l'assemblée de
corps si je ne me trompe mais peut-être
est-ce une erreur j'ai pas payé un
mémoriser ce qu'on m'a dit non la suite
du voyage du président
et bonne fin de de journée tiens sur la
Corse Michel verger franceski il y a si
peu de corps qui parlent le corps ce
aujourd'hui
la langue n'est jamais imposée par un
état ici en ce moment nous parlons pas
du tout la langue de Louis XIV on parle
la langue de Molière en Angleterre on ne
dit jamais la langue d'Henri VIII on dit
la langue de Shakespeare et donc
l'écorce ont le droit de parler corses
en vertu de l'ordonnance de 1539 donc
deux articles n'ont jamais été abrogés
la langue officielle qui a remplacé le
latin c'est le français c'est normal
pour l'éducation pour l'administration
et pour la justice donc c'est la langue
du quotidien
du quotidien c'était la langue de mon
grand-père qui parlait corses en Corse
qui parlait français à Paris alors
qu'est-ce que vous répondez aux
questions que se poser Béatrice Giblin
en prenant l'exemple catalan d'un risque
finalement de de gommage ou des
rééducations de la langue française
est une très très belle idée seulement
quand on est dans un processus
d'affirmation
d'une nation à ce moment-là
le rapport de force parce que c'est
d'une histoire de rapport de force le
rapport de force qui s'instance et de
faire passer la langue qu'on estime être
de sa propre identité devant l'autre et
pour cela il est important effectivement
dans un premier temps on joue des deux
et puis petit à petit on renforce la
langue de sa propre langue parce que
c'est une façon en fait aussi de comment
de se préserver des espaces qui sont des
espaces politiques qui sont des espaces
économique et petit à petit les choses
se referment sur un discours je finis
sur un discours de l'ouverture
alors on est peu nombreux dans la
mondialisation on a le droit d'exister
c'est important qu'on existait la
richesse le patrimoine tout tout ça
c'est des belles paroles mais de fait on
arrive à en fait une fermeture à
réserver aussi
les postes les sièges les voilà et ça
c'est une évolution qu'on voit partout
il faut pas raconter d'histoires on le
voit en Flandre on le voit en catalogue
on le voit au Pays Basque et on le
verrait encore si ça se produisait alors
je fais avancer le déballage la mort
divan Colonna on était en mars 2022
après son agression par un codé tenu en
prison vous vous en souvenez ça avait
provoqué plusieurs nuits des mots de
violence et ouvert la voie finalement à
ces discussions sur l'évolution
institutionnelle de écoutez ce qu’on
disait un manifestant on est dans ce
mois de mars 2022
ça fait 7 ans qui discutent il a fallu
d'une semaine de violence pour que le
gouvernement lâche quelque chose donc il
faut se poser des questions les bonnes
questions peut-être que la violence
qu'on décrit tout le temps peut-être
elle sert à quelque chose
malheureusement
Ivan Colonna je le rappelle condamné
pour avoir assassiné le préfet de Corse
Claude Erignac on était le 6 février 98
à Ajaccio Michel verger franceski est-ce
que ce que dis ce manifestant est juste
la mort de colonel est violence qui ont
suivi nous mène où on est aujourd'hui
c'est-à-dire à une autonomie entrouverte
et un état ne doit pas réagir sur
l'émotion il doit réagir sur la
pérennité et donc ça c'est quand même
très très important alors c'est vrai que
la mort de Colonna à 61 ans au même âge
kerignac 25 ans auparavant 61 tous les
deux lâchement assassinés dans leur dos
sans voir leur assassin ni l'un ni
l'autre et en faisant des pompes l'autre
en sortant du cinéma ça a été la
deuxième trajet dit de ces 25 dernières
années on ne peut que la déplorer être
assassiné en milieu carcéral ça fait
peser effectivement sur la République
une erreur dont la République a bien
conscience puisque pendant 25 ans on a
interdit aux prisonniers corses d'être
emprisonné encore c'est ceci a été une
erreur il faut bien le reconnaître et on
aurait pu éviter ce drame et le premier
il est évident qu'il est odieux et que
j'avais dit à l'époque que c'était pas
des bandits d'honneur mais des bandits
d'horreur Benjamin Morel ce qui s'est
passé dans les jours qui ont suivi la
l'agression puis la mort de d'Yvan
Colonna c'est notamment toute une partie
je dis bien une partie de la jeunesse
Corse qui
alimenter on va dire c'est une nuit de
est-ce que c'est aussi l'enjeu des
prochains mois là et c'est à dire
inverser cette éventuelle radicalisation
d'une partie de la jeunesse problème
c'est que la radicalisation elle passe
par aujourd'hui bien une domination
culturelle regardez l'université de
cortée vous n'avez que des syndicats
indépendantistes à l'université de
cortée à l'université de Corte vous avez
un amphithéâtre qui s'appelle Aquaviva
c'est le nom d'un plastiqueur du FLNC
que croyez-vous quand vous prenez vos
cours dans l'amphita 3 Viva que
pensez-vous que vous puissiez penser
aujourd'hui donc il y a une conquête
culturelle en effet des mouvements
nationalistes voire indépendantistes qui
radicalise une partie de la jeunesse et
là ce qui était annoncé on reviendra
peut-être sur le fond parce que le le
maire dont nous parlions tout à l'heure
avait quand même une vision très éthérée
je crois de ce que annonçait Emmanuel
Macron il a été beaucoup plus flou et ça
ce qu'il proposait à mon avis ne
passerait pas les fourches coding du
Sénat donc il va y avoir de la
frustration c'est le danger du discours
du prêt dans la République faire des
grandes annonces donner aux
nationalistes sur le fond en tout cas
sur la forme ce qu'ils attendent pour
ensuite donner de la frustration c'est
très très danger et ce qui s'est passé
tout de même avec Yvan Colonna la mort
d'Yvan Colonna c'est un drame et c'est
un crime en revanche ça ne fait pas
d'Yvan Colonna un héros quand vous avez
une collectivité qui met en berne ces
drapeaux en l'honneur d'yvant Colonna
quand vous avez une minute de silence
dans l'assemblée de Corse en faveur ils
vont Colonna quand vous avez un ministre
de l'Intérieur je parle je pense à
Gérald Dahmane qui intervient sur une
chaîne concurrente en disant
Ivan Colonna égale Samuel Paty là il y a
quelque chose de réellement choquant et
à ça l'État a cédé l'État a cédé au
violonces qui ont suivi comptez
préfecture etc si jamais l'état cède à
ça si jamais l'état accepte ce type de
discours ça veut dire que quelqu'un qui
a tué dans le dos un préfet de la
République et bien demain peut être
porté en héros et là il y a quand même
une défaillance forte et de l'État et du
président de la République alors je
voudrais vous entendre sur justement la
figure de divan Colonna est-ce que c'est
un héros encore
évidemment c'est trop général ma
question parce que tous les corps vont
pas répondre oui ah en Corse d'ailleurs
le président a parlé de commando ce
matin parce que beaucoup de gens
aujourd'hui quand on en parle doute de
sa culpabilité c'est possible je n'en
sais rien je ne connais aucun des
membres bien entendu du commando mais
beaucoup disent qu'il le regrette parce
que ça n'aurait pas été lui alors que
l'affaire a été jugée elle est passée
aux assises donc moi en tant que
professeur d'université je présidais un
jury en décembre dernier à l'université
de Corte c'est très choquant d'arriver
en voyant sur les murs de l'université
Yvan tu es un héros et de voir également
état français à sa sein et j'ai surpris
un petit peu les étudiants en disant
État français à sa fin vous avez raison
alors ils m'ont dit mais c'est pas
possible et oui c'est Vichy l'État
français c'est Pétain depuis 1945 c'est
terminé si vous êtes contre la
République il faut oser dire je suis
contre la République c'est beaucoup plus
difficile à dire votre avis là-dessus
batterie sur cette figure du héros alors
que revenons effectivement au point de
départ je sais pas si les doutes ne lui
ont pas suffisamment bénéficier lors du
procès mais bon voilà il reste il a été
jugé et il reste l'assassin du mémoire
c'est acté par la justice pour moi c'est
absolument scandaleux de pouvoir en
faire un héros c'est absolument ce qu'on
est le et ça montre bien la dérive dans
lequel on est aujourd'hui en Corse à
pouvoir faire cette confusion vraiment
cette confusion entre un assassin d'un
préfet dont on fait son héros ça veut
dire que c'est une jeune une partie de
la jeunesse Corse qui qui n'a plus les
référents qu'il faut et cet université
de de Corte bon moi aussi professeur
émérite je me suis toujours interrogée
sur était-il judicieux
de faire une université
au cœur de la Corse pour un petit nombre
d'étudiants parce que le
débats
et qu'ils aillent se frotter à tout à
fait d'accord
avec moi mais parce que je pense qu'un
milieu universitaire très étroit très
petit avec des enseignants qui sont
quand même très engagés pour une grande
partie d'entre eux qui tolèrent qu'on
puisse écrire sur sur les mots et tables
français assassin n'ouvre pas alors
qu'on nous parle d'ouverture n'ouvre pas
ces jeunes à au débat à la contradiction
à l'esprit critique à tout ce qui est la
formation qu'on doit donner à
l'université mais c'est là encore une
forme d'enfermement et je trouve que
c'est ceci permet des dérives et dernier
mot dans une société dans laquelle
aujourd'hui les dérives mafieuses sont
extrêmement graves on n'essaiera parlé
de parler de qui a le pouvoir notamment
le pouvoir économique j'espère qu'on
aura le temps parce qu'il y a d'abord un
grand chapitre forcément à consacrer
vous avez commencé à l’évoquer à la
question constitutionnelle qui est
évidemment majeure
je propose d'attendre traduit de nous
rejoindre tout de suite sur ce plateau
puisqu'on va bonsoir tard avec vous
rentrez un peu dans le détail Emmanuel
Macron on l'a compris propose de faire
entrer la Corse dans la Constitution une
révision constitutionnelle qui s'annonce
le mauvais peut-être même faible pas
évidente oui le président de la
République d'ailleurs et bien il est
bien prévenu puisqu'il a déjà échoué sur
ce terrain lors de son premier mandat
des 2017 dans la foulée de son élection
Emmanuel Macron annonce une réforme
constitutionnelle alors à l'époque on
parle notamment d'un texte large qui
prévoit de réduire le nombre de
parlementaires qui prévoit
l'introduction d'une dose de
proportionnelle mais qui prévoit aussi
l'inscription de la Corse dans la
Constitution avec un article un article
72-5 qui donne à la Corse un statut
particulier et qui reconnaît à l'île de
beauté des spécificités liées à son
insularité ainsi qu'à ses
caractéristiques géographiques
économiques ou sociales on est donc
alors en 2017 je le disais c'est le
forêt en macronie majorité écrasante à
l'Assemblée Emmanuel Macron pense
pouvoir emprunter la voie rapide que ça
va prendre un an en réalité ça va
devenir un long chemin de croix car pas
de réforme possible sans accord du Sénat
elle est pour parler vont finir par
s'enliser ça pas beaucoup changé la
situation là-dessus il faut toujours
l'accord du Sénat pour mener cette
réforme ah oui petit rappel de droit
constitutionnel il y a pas 50 façons de
réformer la loi fondamentale la
principale c'est donc le recours à
l'article
89 de la Constitution qui prévoit que
pour faire aboutir une telle réforme il
faut d'abord que le Sénat et l'Assemblée
nationale se mettent d'accord sur un
même texte et puis vous avez deux
possibilités pour faire adopter ce texte
soit l'adoption en congrès avec l'accord
de 3/5 des parlementaires soit le
référendum mais dans tous les cas si
vous n'avez pas l'accord du Sénat vous
n'avez pas de réformes et pour l'instant
la majorité sénatoriale de droite et de
centre droit ici au Sénat et Emmanuel
Macron sont pas sur la même ligne oui
Bruno Retailleau le patron dessinateur
les républicains à tracer ses lignes
rouges dans un entretien donné à
Corse-Matin c'était avant le déplacement
du président de la République il dit que
cette autonomie ne peut figurer qu'à
l'article 72 de la Constitution alors
qu'Emmanuel Macron et bien a dit qu'il
pouvait se trouver dans un article
propre ensuite le sénateur veut bien de
l'autonomie a-t-il dit mais avec une
définition bien restrictive il ne faut
surtout pas qu'on aille vers un statut
proche de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie surtout pas de
pouvoir législatif propre or Emmanuel
Macron on l'a dit vient d'ouvrir la
porte pour que les élus de Corse
puissent légiférer sur des domaines bien
précis même si on est bien d'accord ça
reste bien flou enfin Bruno Retailleau
rappelle bien dans son interview il n'y
aura aucun accord sans le Sénat et même
c'est encore plus vrai sur un texte
relatif à l'organisation territoriale de
la République c'est le Sénat qui est
saisi en première lecture là-dessus on
ne sait pas c'est Emmanuel Macron peut
répliquer sauf à sortir le très
controversé article 11 de la
Constitution qui permet de soumettre
directement un référendum tout projet de
loi portant sur l'organisation des
pouvoirs publics comprend donc
contourner le Parlement bon c'est un
article qui n'a pas été utilisé depuis
1969 à l'époque il avait entraîné la
chute du général de Gaulle c'est donc un
petit peu le monde d'hier effectivement
merci beaucoup Thomas pour ces détails
mercredi prochain d'ailleurs Emmanuel
Macron sera devant le conseil émotionnel
à l'occasion des du 65e anniversaire de
la Constitution Benjamin Morel on va en
savoir peut-être un petit peu plus à ce
moment là oui je pense qu'on saura en
tout cas quelque chose qui est quel va
être le statut de ce projet loi sur la
Corse est-ce que c'est un projet de loi
particulier singulier et je dirais
autonome auquel cas en effet il va
falloir définir réellement ce que c'est
autonomie parce que Emmanuel Macron
parle de pouvoir normatif sous le
contrôle du Conseil d'État et du Conseil
constitutionnel ça peut vouloir dire
plein de choses ça peut vouloir dire la
Nouvelle-Calédonie et je le rappelle
selon les accords Nouma est un
territoire en boîte décolonisation ce
qui impliquerait de faire de la Corse
une colonie bizarre mais l'unité de la
République c'est l'unité du législateur
si on donne un poids législatif à la
Corse on rompt clairement l'unité de la
République ça peut vouloir directe même
si c'est seulement sur certains domaines
précis l'unité de la l'unité du
législateur pour avoir ensuite une
capacité avec des lois qui peuvent
concerner certains territoires mais
l'unité du législateur en l'occurrence
le Sénat et l'Assemblée nationale ça ça
ne se négocie pas donc là il y aura pas
d'accord avec le Sénat en tout cas je ne
crois pas de l'autre côté
contrôler par le Conseil d'État c'est
constitutionnel ça peut également être
et bien la possibilité dans le cadre du
loi d'accorder un certain nombre de
marge de manœuvre réglementaire à la
collectivité auquel cas on est dans
quelque chose qui ressemble beaucoup à
ce qui a été annonçant en 2019 je pense
que le maire que dont vous avez pas à
qui on a parlé tout à l'heure très très
content si on lui promet ça vous voyez
que le delta est très très fort c'est ce
qu'on propose notamment la droite
sénatoriale et Bruno Retailleau donc il
y a loin de la coupe aux lèvres donc on
va savoir si c'est un projet loi pour
répondre finement à votre question si
c'est un projet de loi autonome ou si
c'est un projet loi fourre-tout parce
que si jamais vous arrivez avec un
projet de loi constitutionnel dans
lequel vous mettez l'immigration
référendum possible à l'article 11 la
gauche quel que soit sa position sur la
gauche sur la Corse de le vote pas si
donc on aura il nous manquera toujours
pour arriver au 3e si vous mettez l'IVG
et l'environnement l'article premier la
droite va avoir du mal à le voter et
donc à ce moment-là vous envoyez un
projet de loi qui n'a aucune chance de
passer et qui permet de mettre tout le
monde en porte-à-faux politiquement
c'est malin mais sur la Corse c'est très
dangereux parce comme je le disais tout
à l'heure le jour où et bien les nations
vont se réveiller et comprendre que et
bien on leur a promis la lune pour
finalement accoucher d'une souris il
peut y avoir de la violence parce qu'il
y a des discours de ce matin évidemment
à fenêtre un certain nombre d'espoirs
de Bruno Retailleau à Corse-Matin
c'était en début de semaine c'est ce
lundi il définissait un certain nombre
de lignes rouges on va on va lire
ensemble un autre extrait la notion de
peuple corse conduirait au séparatisme
et l'expression de ce principe à la
co-officialité ou au statut de résidence
c'est-à-dire à créer juridiquement et de
fait deux catégories de citoyens la
Corse qui traite alors la République
française ce n'est pas ce que je
souhaite Béatrice Gibelin
là je suis en train de dire ce qui est
manuel Macron qui est quand même un
saint politique et pas en train de
calculer de faire porter au LR
finalement au sénateur LR la
responsabilité de l'échec de l'autonomie
parce que c'est un peu ce qui se profile
à l'autre que c'est son calcul ce qui me
semble d'un calcul éminemment dangereux
parce que moi je rejoins complètement
Benjamin Morel sur la frustration que ça
va générer en particulier chez des
jeunes indépendantistes qui ont envie
d'en découdre bon et déjà comment ils
ont réagi au moment de l'assassinat de
Colona qui a entraîné effectivement de
nouveaux la discussion alors ils auront
l'impression d'avoir été complètement
floués et la violence peut parfaitement
resurgir et il y aura des tas de gens
pour utiliser cela de façon à j'allais
dire déstabiliser une société ça permet
de faire des ouvertures pour pouvoir se
glisser
demande la reconnaissance de ce terme et
depuis la République ça n'est plus
possible et depuis quand surtout depuis
un Corse c'est Napoléon le premier qui a
créé la notion de peuple de peuple
français je souhaite être enterré au
bord de la Seine auprès de ce peuple que
j'ai tant aimé aucun roi de France
n'était uniquement au roi de France
Louis XII Louis XIV Henri IV à Toulon y
signé roi de France et de Navarre
virgule compte de Provence compte de
Forcalquier à Rennes signé duc de
Bretagne donc il y avait un ensemble de
peuples donc on a tort encore ce de
sarcouter sur quelque chose qui ne peut
pas être donné de toute façon par la
République parce que si la République
reconnaît le peuple Corse il faut
reconnaître le peuple alsacien le peuple
des Pyrénées-Orientales catalan le
peuple masque le peuple ça n'est pas du
jacobinisme français c'est la
Constitution ce livre est excellent sur
la France en miettes que vous avez écrit
Benjamin parce que la France c'est ça si
on en revient à la notion un amiral de
France comme Coligny il était amiral de
quoi dit le de France c'est-à-dire
uniquement de Normandie c'est-à-dire des
côtes qui dépendaient qui étaient du
ressort du Parlement de Paris et donc
l'ensemble de la collectivité française
repose sur cette réunion de compter de
duché d'Auvergne etc et la France c'est
comme ça donc demandez la reconnaissance
du peuple corse qui est un mot qui
existe sous la plume de Voltaire qui
existe sous la plume de Rousseau depuis
la Révolution ça n'est plus possible
mais est-ce que ça peut faire partie là
je reviens au présent et à ce ces six
mois de discussion qui vont s'ouvrir
c'est ce qui est manuel Macron a annoncé
avec le gouvernement pourrait aboutir à
un texte constitutionnel
à quoi on peut assister est-ce qu'on
peut assister à une sorte de de
surenchère de de certains
indépendantistes justement pour ou alors
au contraire est-ce qu'ils font ça il y
a une occasion là à sais
il y a des choses que l'on demande et
que l'on ne pourra jamais obtenir c'est
ce qui est dommage c'est de s'accouter
parce que quand on dit qu'on dialogue il
faut dialoguer d'une façon réelle et
aujourd'hui on assiste à des reculades
moi ce que j'ai entendu ce matin
d'Emmanuel Macron qui cite tant le
général de Gaulle dit au sujet de
l'anniversaire de 1943 de Gaulle a dit
la Corse premier territoire
libéré et non il a dit premier morceau
de la France libéré donc on est obligé
aujourd'hui de transformer les nos
citations de De Gaulle pour ne pas
offenser les populations et donc
l'expression de territoire ces gens qui
tolamone qui est un ami que je connais
très bien que je respecte beaucoup et
bien ce qu'il a employé pour ne plus
dire justement et donc Emmanuel Macron a
pris
le langage nationaliste d'accord on l'a
bien compris Laetitia il faut le
reconnaître se déplace dans un
territoire souvent ou s'adapte à ces
différents interlocuteurs alors un des
principaux handicaps Laetitia d'Emmanuel
Macron dans cette relation avec les
corps c'est l'absence d'un monsieur
Corse un interlocuteur qui pourrait
justement faciliter le dialogue oui
c'est ça explique en grande partie je
pense les atermoins d'un Emmanuel Macron
qui arrive en 2017 au pouvoir et je peux
vous dire que quand vous discutez avec
notamment l'état-major un des
nationalistes corses ils vous disent
c'est simple on a été traité comme des
corps intermédiaires c'est-à-dire qu'on
n'a pas été traité du tout et c'est vrai
que Manuel Macron n'a pas de Monsieur
Corse comme elle avait ses prédécesseurs
quand on regarde par exemple François
Mitterrand François Mitterrand il avait
Michel charas il avait aussi je ne sais
pas si c'est de votre famille mais
Joseph franceski secrétaire d'État à la
sécurité publique auprès de Gaston
Defferre qui était alors ministre de
l'Intérieur et puis Jacques Chirac on le
sait tous il avait Charles Pasqua
Nicolas Sarkozy lui connaissait très
bien le terrain pourquoi parce que dès
son arrivée au ministère de l'Intérieur
il s'était déplacé encore et avait
constitué un tissu de relation assez
solide c'est vrai qu'avec François
Hollande ça a commencé un peu bon à
s'effilocher mais finalement les
relations étaient plutôt normalisées on
s'en est pas rendu compte et là avec la
mort d'Yvan Colonna tout a basculé et le
siège vide du monsieur Corse a sauté aux
yeux oui on l'a évoqué c'est à partir de
ce moment-là que Emmanuel Macron
étoffe ses discussions on va dire avec
les nationalistes et remet la Corse dans
ses priorités échange complètement de
fusil d'épaules mais vous l'avez tous
dit il l'a fait sous la contrainte si
jamais bon de faire quelque chose un
acte politique au même volonté politique
de la mener sous la contrainte pour eux
c'était quel contrainte il y avait une
menace d'une reprise d'un temps il faut
dire les mots il y a encore aujourd'hui
des violences on en parle pas beaucoup
mais quand on parle avec l'écorce on m'a
dit hier que j'ai eu des Corses au
téléphone on m'a dit dans le sud de
l'île Thomas il y a encore des villas
qui sont cramées voilà qui sautent donc
il y a aujourd'hui un risque le réel
vous avez raison Béatrice de le dire il
risque de réel de reprise alors faute de
Monsieur Corse il s'est appuyé sur qui
est sur le ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald Darmanin et c'est vrai que
finalement ça a fonctionné à force de
rencontre à force de dialogue les corps
sont accepté Gérald Darmanin pourquoi
parce qu'elle est ministre de
l'Intérieur donc il a une certaine
légitimité ils ont accepté que ce soit
l'interlocuteur les mystères de l'Élysée
finalement dans ses négociations est-ce
qu'il va continuer à le faire là pour
les 6 mois à venir on verra bien mais
pour l'instant c'est Gérald Darmanin qui
a cette casquette de Monsieur Corse
Béatrice Gibelin est-ce que c'est un jeu
de dupe auquel on est en train
d'assister
je prendrai pas cette expression de jeu
de dupe
je la prendrais pas je pense que pour
une partie des élus corses autonomistes
nationalistes
ils sont séduits on sait que le
Président c'est séducteur ils sont
séduits et ils ont envie de faire
avancer un peu les pions
un écho très très positif comme si on
aurait on allait avoir du mal à
reculer
mais je pense qu'ils y croient je pense
que
ils ont en tout cas ils ont envie d'y
croire là où je suis plus encore plus
dubitatif c'est leur entente interne
entre corps et ça j'ai quand même pas
mal de doutes parce que entre y compris
avec Angelini qui est quand même une
partie de la nation corse c'est pas non
plus le parti de siméonie et pas vous et
tout ça quand il va falloir se mettre
d'accord dans 6 mois pour aller faire un
texte de consensus de façon à pouvoir
présenter quelque chose très sincèrement
je pense qu'on n'y est pas parce que
justement vous savez c'est quand même on
est peu nombreux encore moi je reviens
là-dessus on se on se connaît et il y a
des risques à trahir je mets des
guillemets à trahir ce qui est sont des
soutiens ou autre donc et ben des plus
indépendantistes par exemple qui
voudraient accepter
une proposition d'autonomie on va dire
raisonnable pas se rendre pour des
traîtres à leur propre camp ça veut dire
qu'il perde à ce moment-là des soutiens
électoraux mais peut-être beaucoup plus
que ça il y a quand même parfois des
règlements qui se passent de façon on va
dire violente tout autant donc dans une
petite société on n'est même pas en
Catalogne ou c'est plus de 4 millions
d'habitants là on est quand même
à 130 000 habitants c'est très peu c'est
très peu et ce que je finis juste là
en plus une démocratie qui sur le plan
du sol naturel et négatif et de
croissance qu'avec l'apport extérieur
c'est le solde migratoire qui fait ça
c'est pas d'écorce qui arrive donc cette
idée d'un peuple corse qui est à mon
sens complètement mifié aujourd'hui dans
la mesure où un tiers de la population
qui naissent de cette autonomie possible
par exemple écoutez Marie-Antoinette
Maupertuis qui est présidente de
l'Assemblée de corps c'est assez
frappant
50 années d'incompréhension
de frustration
d'espoir déçu et de drames individuels
et collectifs 50 années un demi-siècle
il est temps il est grand temps
aujourd'hui de donner à cette jeunesse
au corps les moyens d'assurer les
conditions de sa propre existence voire
de sa survie faire face aux défis
globaux tout en maintenant vivante ses
valeurs et son idée d'entité plurielle
dans une Corse apaisée
décomplexé dans sa relation à la
République française et passionnément
européenne
Michel Berger Franceschi ça changerait
quoi une Corse autonome en matière
économique est-ce que le pouvoir
économique changerait changerait demain
c'est c'est la première question qu'il
faut se poser alors moi je suis toujours
un peu gêné parce que ce sont des amis
un être mot Pertuis ma collègue les
agrets d'économie de l'université de
Corte quand j'ai besoin de
d'iconographie pour un bouquin elle a
fait un excellent travail dans le
domaine du tourisme etc
tout à fait j'ai une opinion libre mais
bon j'ai déjeuné avec Angelini au mois
d'août je vois la question c'est combien
de familles possède le pouvoir
économique en Corse c'est pour ça que je
parlais du retour au Moyen-Âge c'est
l'équivalent d'une trentaine de
seigneurs locaux qui sont à des
carrefours économiques qui ne sont plus
dans des Castets ou des tours mais c'est
la même chose c'est la maîtrise d'un
territoire c'est un territoire
immobilier au lieu d'être un territoire
militaire il y a 5 ou 600 ans et on
revoit en refleurir l'ancienne situation
médiévale avec les assassinats qui
étaient extrêmement nombreux vous prenez
la famille de gentil 12 assassinats dans
la famille au 14e 15e siècle donc c'est
un retour au passé donc l'autonomie
c'est pour ça que je disais ça tout à
l'heure on l'a connu on l'a vécu et moi
je suis pour la défense extrêmement du
regalien il faut que l'État la justice
l'éducation nationale l'université etc
pèse et pèse encore plus dans une île
qui en a besoin parce que là on a tous
vu un petit peu trop les défauts
peut-être mais il y a des choses qu'on
ne pourra jamais corriger l'insularité
moi j'aime à dire que les frontières de
la Corse elles sont dues peut-être à
Dieu mais elles sont éternelles les
frontières de la France les Pyrénées
l'Alsace leur a etc tout ça a changé
c'est dû à l'homme et donc c'est ça qui
crée l'identité d'une île une île elle
est très forte parce qu'elle a toujours
eu ses frontières elle les avait déjà à
l'époque de Sénèque ou à l'époque de
Cicéron les deux les autres handicaps le
soleil tout le monde cherche le soleil
donc c'est le tourisme la mère et par
conséquent tous les problèmes qui en
découlent les problèmes de résident le
coût des maisons etc on a la même chose
à l'île de Ré alors on parle souvent de
comparaison c'est une erreur avec la
Polynésie moi je retrouve les mêmes
revendications à lu le douessant sous
Louis XIII
à Bréhat dans les îles de Lérins et une
chose dernier mot pourquoi le père de
Pascal Paoli a été il fait marquer parce
que la Corse est une marche du royaume
comme le marquis de Porquerolles le
marquis d'Ouessant le marc et c'était
tous des Marquis et donc là on a on
comprend que l'île de Corse est
indépendante et elle est nécessaire au
royaume à la France aujourd'hui à la
République c'est une marche toujours
protégée le premier port de guerre
français Toulon le premier port de
commerce français
jusqu'au jour où les Anglais ont pris
Gibraltar et à ce moment-là c'est
Bordeaux et Brest qui ont supplanté les
précédents magnifiques le tour
d'histoire merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat il faut
lire le livre de Benjamin Morel la
France en miette on est vraiment si ce
débat vous a passionné comme nous on est
vraiment au cœur de la question de voilà
de de l'entité républicaine de l'unité
républicaine et ses publie aux éditions
du Cerf et Béatrice Gibelin je conseille
évidemment la lecture de la revue et
redote je vous dis à tous à bientôt sur
public S